the anarchist act next on book TV
Christopher finan explores the history
of free speech in from the Palmer Raids
to the Patriot Act this is 45 minutes I
am delighted to be here for Chris and to
talk about his new book and talk a
little bit about Chris uh some years ago
there was legislation that some of you
are familiar with called the USA patriot
act and this was a bad piece of
legislation to begin with and as part of
that legislation there was a section
that dealt section 218 that essentially
would have allowed the FBI to go into
libraries and to go into bookstores and
to ascertain what you what books you
have borrowed or what books you have
purchased and guess what you don't know
anything about that and furthermore if
the bookstore or the library were to
make that issue public they would be in
violation of the law and subject to
severe penalties that seemed to me and
by the way the FBI could do this without
ascertaining or determining any probable
cause any reason to believe that
somebody was a terrorist that seemed to
be a be a pretty dumb idea a pretty
unconstitutional idea and I worked with
the American librarians Association the
Vermont librarians Association and
booksellers throughout the country and
at the head of that whole effort of
publicizing what was going on and
rallying opposition to that section and
to the USA PATRIOT was Chris fine it and
what Chris has done over the years is to
remind all of us about what our
Constitution is about and we hope that
President Bush of you Chris have you
gotten this look to the president yet we
hope that the president tries to learn
what the Constitution is about and we
hope that the president understands that
we are a nation of
and despite the very serious threats of
international terrorism we have a
constitution which must be maintained so
right now we are laboring in my view
under a president who has assaulted this
constitution time after time after time
and therefore Chris's book comes at a
very important moment and it's a moment
that we have to educate and re-educate
the American people about civil
liberties about the Bill of Rights and
especially young people issue would be
amazed at how many young people really
don't understand what constitutional
rights are about we're fighting
terrorism gee I guess we have to suspend
our basic rights in order to do that
well obviously we don't we all want to
be effective in fighting terrorism if we
want to do it in a way that sustains and
maintains what our Constitution is about
and what American freedom is about so I
just I've gotta run and catch a plane
but I just want to thank Chris and his
organization for their valiant fights
sometimes unpopular year after year
after year to protect basic
constitutional rights his book is
extremely important at this particular
moment in history so it gives me a great
deal of pleasure to introduce Chris fine
I am of course very honored to have been
introduced by senator Sanders who I've
got to know over the last three or four
years in this fight and it's hard to
exaggerate the importance of his role in
that fight six years ago last time I
stood up and addressed an audience in
Washington was six years ago it was six
months after the anniversary was a
six-month anniversary of the Patriot Act
and I had come to Washington with a
bunch of other free expression people we
joined with the ACLU and with the
national coalition against censorship
and epic and a lot of groups that are in
fact members are here in the audience to
dine to draw attention to the free
speech threats posed by the Patriot Act
and I can tell you that looking out at
the audience today is a much more
reassuring experience than the
experience I had that day because we
were up there we had a great program we
had a sterling cast and there was one
reporter six months after the Patriot
Act six months seven months after the
911 attacks nobody was thinking about
free speech except the civil
libertarians and a year after that as
Bernie said a group of Vermont
librarians and booksellers circulated a
petition and asked their representatives
in Congress to take up this fight over
reader privacy the fight to amend
section 215 and to restore the
safeguards for reader privacy that had
been eliminated that it had eliminated
and the importance of it and what
happened is surprisingly to us I mean we
were kind of stunned when he responded
and said that he would take this on it
was a brave thing to do he was one of
only 66 members of the house to vote
against the Patriot Act there was only
one vote in the Senate that was brave
enough
to then announced that he was going to
introduce the freedom to read Protection
Act and make civil liberties a political
issue was incredibly brave and we did
everything that we could to support him
we launched petition campaign bookstores
and libraries around the country talked
to their customers we begin to get
pressed for the issue and for the first
time the Patriot Act which up until that
point had been seen as absolutely
essential legislation in every respect
began to be picked apart and the parts
of it that are good we have no problems
with the problems that threaten civil
liberties of course we do and and we
continue to and and as a result of that
political campaign that senator Sanders
launched we were able to make some
changes at the time that the the bill
came up for reauthorization last year
and we are going to continue to fight
that fight it's the fight that he
started and gave credibility to and and
so that's why I'm I'm so moved by his
being here today it seems almost
sacrilegious or blasphemous to say this
in a country in which the First
Amendment to the Constitution protects
freedom of speech and freedom of the
press but the fact is there's always
been censorship in America seven years
after the passage of the First Amendment
which was in 1791 seven only seven years
later one half of the founding fathers
the Federalists were trying to throw the
other half of the funding father's the
Jeffersonians in jail for what they had
to say about the government under the
Alien and Sedition Acts so we've never
had a pure a pure country it has always
been a contentious issue and it grew to
become particularly contentious after
the Civil War when a number of important
social fights kind of moved to the fore
in American politics the most important
in terms of numbers and also that it
affected was the labor movement the
labor movement the effort to organize
unions to to bargain collectively with
the increasingly large companies and
corporations in this country was met
with violent often violent resistance by
the cap owners of capital they didn't
want their workers joining unions and if
you were somebody who joined a union
[ __ ] there was a good chance that a spy
in that union would tell your boss that
you belong to the union and you would be
fired if you didn't get fired you would
have a hard time in many places in this
country holding a union meeting because
one of two things would happen either
the police would close it down police
sympathetic to the local power structure
or goons would break it up if you did
manage to hold your meeting and you
decided to have a strike and then you
you ventured forth to pick it he'd have
a good chance of getting your head
broken and if you didn't get your head
broken and nobody was messing with you
at all you often faced an injunction
from the courts like this injunction
that was it that was enacted in Seattle
in the in the early 20th century it
prohibited quote using in any way any
language tending to incite the
defendants auditors or the public to
lawlessness or tending in any way to
arouse the anger and incite the
antagonism or wrath of the citizens and
also from using any violence or abusive
language of any kind toward the United
States government the state of
Washington or the City of Seattle or its
public officials and from using language
ridiculing the institutions of this
country in other words you better shut
up you could have your labor protest but
you couldn't say anything the right of
free speech was not was a dead letter
for labor in this country for many years
in addition there was on the
books of this country something called
the Comstock act passed in 1873 which
was used by Anthony Comstock and other
defenders of Victorian morality to
hassle people who challenged the
existing sexual status quo that is
people feminists who argued that women
should have equality in marriage that in
many cases they argue that the
institution of marriage itself should be
abolished they were radicals but that
wasn't a reason to suppress them but
that was what Anthony Comstock did he he
prosecuted the feminists editor victoria
woodhull he imposed succeeded in getting
a court to impose a thirty-five hundred
dollar fine on a doctor Edward foot for
mailing a birth control pamphlet Ezra
Heywood escaped jail just by virtue of a
presidential pardon because he advocated
that sexual relations were no business
of the state and diem Bennett
unfortunately served 13 months in prison
for selling a tract advocating free love
so that the the Comstock Act succeeded
in many for many years in being a
significant barrier to the feminist
movement in this country and also as an
attack on artistic freedom as well
because it band of course not just
feminist tracks but also obscene and
indecent material and sometimes that
that material wasn't great stuff for
example there was this this is an
excerpt from a novel an English novel
called three weeks in which the heroine
says beautiful savage Paul 30 year old
married heroine whispers to her young
paramour do you love me when Paul
enthusiastically agrees she continues
then said the lady in a voice in which
all the caresses of the world seem
melted then sweet Paul I shall teach you
many things and among them I shall teach
you how to live that was banned as
obscene in 1907 in Boston
not great literature probably nothing to
really cry about but the sensors went on
over the course of the next couple of
decades in Boston to ban American
mercury magazine Sinclair Lewis is Elmer
Gantry theater Dreiser's American
tragedy upton sinclair's oil Ernest
Hemingway's farewell to arms Eugene
O'Neill's Strange Interlude and books by
Bertrand Russell hg wells sherwood
anderson william faulkner John Dos
Passos and Ben Hecht culminating in 1929
in the spectacular prosecution of a
Cambridge bookseller for selling that
most band of all books th Lawrence's
Lady Chatterley's Lover so there was
censorship galore in the united states
throughout its history but most of it
occurred at the state and local level
and therefore really didn't trigger a
national response a national civil
liberties movement really awaited the
outrages of World War one in part the
the reason that wasn't an action earlier
was that the federal government itself
was so small and powerless before World
War World War one but in the war
suddenly it took on all these powers
that it needed to to mobilize the
population including the Espionage Act
which gave it the power to act against
anti-war criticism and there was a
significant amount of anti-war criticism
during World War one so the government
proceeded to ban the anti-war movement
it banned the magazine the masses for
four articles and four cartoons one of
the cartoons was a cartoon of a
crumbling Liberty Bell there were in
addition to the actions against the
press 2,000 over 2,000 prosecutions of
individual American citizens for
anti-war statements ranging from the
very inane the president is a fat head
to the Gravitron der statements by such
leaders of the socialist movement as
Eugene Debs who said in a speech in
Canton you need to know that you're
you're fit for something better than
slavery and cannon fodder
for that he got 10 years in jail and
served two and a half years before he
was finally released early these
outrages coupled with at the very end
just after the end of the war with the
Palmer Raids the raids in which
thousands of immigrants were picked up
for membership in one of the common one
of the two communist parties in the
country at that time alerted the country
and in a significant body of its
citizens to the dangers of censorship
and resulted in the launching of the
American Civil Liberties Union in 1920
the Civil of the Civil Liberties Union's
first and major priority throughout the
its first decade of the 20s was to
protect the labor movement and to try to
assert the rights of free speech for
four members of labor often by sending
lawyers naked Lee into dangerous
situations to assert the right to hold
meetings and I have a an example of what
happened to one of the ACLU lawyers when
he tried in the spring of nineteen
twenty two Roger Baldwin the head of the
ACLU telephoned New York Attorney Arthur
Garfield Hays to tell him that the
Pennsylvania miners had gone out on
strike and asked him to participate in a
protest in closed town with umw
officials Baldwin downplayed the
difficulty of the assignment Hayes later
recalled no it won't take long Baldwin
said you'll arrive in the early morning
and hold your meeting and be back in the
evening Hayes had a pleasant drive down
through the mountains of eastern
Pennsylvania but the union officials
told him that the job wouldn't be easy
they chose the town of Vinton Dale
because they had been unable to get a
foothold there one of their men had been
escorted out of town at the point of a
shotgun a couple of weeks earlier a
reporter from the New York Herald had
also been turned away Hayes told union
officials that he would be happy to
accompany them and make sure that the
police did not disrupt their meeting
this was not received with much
enthusiasm hey said quote but
someone suggested that attorneys Hayes
do the talking there was unanimous and
spirited approval Hayes several union
officials and two reporters set off in
two cars amid beautiful scenery they
passed squalid villages dominated by
mountainous coal domes on reaching
Vinton Dale the Union drivers gun their
engines rushing by a swearing century
they soon heard the clatter of hooves as
they were pursued into the center of
town by armed horsemen their pursuers
were members of the coal and iron police
a state police force that was paid by
the coal operators we know you you
bastards one yelled your union
organizers get the hell out of this town
Hayes emerged from his car full of fire
who are you men he demanded where's the
post office where's the mayor's office
we'd like to see the ordinances of this
town instead one of the troopers pointed
to a sign that said the sheriff would
arrest anyone who created a public
disorder I see it what of it the lawyer
asked I'm going to stand here as long as
I damn please Hayes recalled the
reaction bus this up or we'll bust you
up shouts one while hoots threats and
curses come from the others finally one
Arbogast the coal company controller
with the assistance of one of the
troopers in a bystander grabs me by the
nape of the neck and the seat of the
trousers while others are busy with my
companions there was then impressed on
me a clear conviction verified by other
experiences to wit when one is in that
position he may talk constitutional law
insist upon his rights as an American
citizen he may proclaim the Declaration
of Independence but all the dignity is
on the side of the authorities it wasn't
easy to be a civil libertarian in the
1920s it makes today look like a piece
of cake and they often remembered in
later years does heroic kind of ventures
into these dangerous towns as the time
when we were all jailbirds together and
it seemed like a lonely it seemed like a
lonely task but in fact that's free
speech movement was growing even as the
ACLU encountered this strong resistance
on the labor front in the book industry
publishers and booksellers and
librarians began to make a strategic
change of position on censorship once
arbiters of moral taste and defenders of
the public against bad books in the 20s
they become advocates of of the right of
their customers and patrons to make
their own decisions about what they want
to read the courts which had up to that
point been so hostile to free speech
begin to turn around in the 1930s and
over the next over the course of the
next 40 years hand down one landmark
decision after another that widens the
the protections of free speech for all
and left the situation in which the
Supreme Court which had formerly
abstained from these kinds of cases as
the final arbiter of free speech in
America and even Congress which often
played a not a constructive role in free
speech passed critical legislation that
protected the rights of workers under
the Wagner Act which is one of the the
National Labor Relations Act allowed an
enfranchised labor protected the right
to join a union protected the right to
picket and strike past the Freedom of
Information Act in 1966 and strengthened
it in 1974 and passed the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act in 1978 to
curb spying by the nation's intelligence
agencies the FBI the NSA and CIA now
when you leave the Congressional
achievements with FISA we come to the
present into the problem because as many
of you know the administration has
ignored FISA and has authorized it
authorized the NSA to engage in in
tapping of phones without
authority from any court if we are
brought today to this point that the
country has this experience the country
has had several times first in the world
first world war then in following the
Second World War and now today we're
fear of foreign threats of Communists in
the first in the first and second case
and then terrorists today and where it
has taken that fear and used it as a
license to expand its efforts to protect
its own secrets to expand secrecy while
in invading our secrets and expanding
surveillance this has been historically
a tragic combination because it has
invited government to actually step
beyond surveillance and just watching
what we do to actually disrupting groups
that it considered disloyal and the the
best examples of that were in the 50s
and the 60s when the FBI in fact had so
much consumed knew so much through
bugging and wiretapping and burglaries
about what the Communist Party was about
that it could have taken over the
Communist Party if it wanted to it had
won it controlled one of the the main
factions it was a it was a powerful
temptation to destroy it all together
but at that point the Communist Party
was largely dead anyway but it did it
took the same approach then two other
domestic dissident groups it acted
against the anti-war movement it acted
against the civil rights movement it
created it it engaged in one of the
single most shameful acts in American
history it tried to blackmail Martin
Luther King into dropping out of
leadership of the civil rights movement
with tapes that were allegedly made in
his hotel rooms and contained sounds of
sexual activity the dangers for American
freedom at this point in time are
as high as they've been in many many
years but i'm personally optimistic i
personally think that when you look back
at the long history of the growth of
free speech that we have a lot of reason
to to take hope and to continue to fight
for to continue to fight for free speech
and a quote that I I particularly like
from justice learn at hand in 1944 he he
observed that Liberty lies in the hearts
of men and women when it dies there no
Constitution no law no court can save it
but I think there is a lot of evidence
in over the last six years that in fact
the passion for liberty remains very
strong in the days after the 911 attacks
civil liberties groups gathered in the
offices of the ACLU to concert strategy
for the onslaught that they knew that
was coming I wasn't personally at that
meeting I'm sorry I wasn't there but
there were a hundred and fifty
organizations represented they spilled
into the into the garden of the ACLU
people were sitting on the stairs that's
how big the free speech movement had
become in 90 years bookstores and
libraries got busy as Bernie explained
in talking to their customers and their
patrons about the threat to their their
civil liberties and they got a response
and this was not a this was not an easy
thing for for either group both groups
have every reason to be cautious about
how they approach their customers and
patrons and booksellers in particular
but they they got active and launched a
campaign and we collected in a matter of
a couple of months hundreds of thousands
of signatures in opposition to section
215 in support of Bernie's bill and
finally the last piece of evidence that
was so encouraging was the 400
communities including many of the
largest cities in this country and eight
states that passed aunty Patriot Act
resolutions and gave Bernie the kind of
ammunition that he needed when he took
his case to the floor of the house and
we actually passed the freedom to read
act it was passed as an amendment to an
appropriations bill so ultimately it
didn't become law but a majority of the
House of Representatives voted for this
legislation and it was very important
when he we came time to reauthorize the
Patriot Act to point to this as proof of
the support for changes in the law so my
experience both as a scholar of the Free
Speech Movement and as an activist
myself is that there are many brave
individuals in this country and who are
determined to fight for their freedom
and as long as they are the fight for
free speech will continue thanks very
much questions basically most of the
paranoia as from the executive office
when when this administration goes away
most of us are presuming that the light
will come out and and things will will
get better do you see it differently the
Matthew you well I certainly hope you're
right and and I think that there are
things about this administration that
you can point to it that from the
beginning this is an administration that
has been devoted to secrecy this is
administration you know that is staffed
by men like Dick Cheney and informally
Rumsfeld who were instrumental in
persuading President Ford to veto the
law strengthening the Freedom of
Information Act which was then passed
over his veto these are secrecy guys and
even though all executive officers you
can expect to want to expand their
privileges and protect their information
I think this is a this is an
exceptionally zealous group so I hope
you're right
Kevin would you say that some of this is
just cyclical obviously there's a big
push back and free speech in response to
specific events but over time is there
evidence that it just sort of moves back
and forth with culture generally or well
I think a lot of the changes that have
been made or permanent I mean I think I
think that their internet it what seems
cyclical in particular is the national
security stuff it's cyclical to the
extent that every time there's a serious
threat to our security government tends
to overreact but we've defended we've
protected artistic speech to a much
greater extent that it ever existed
before there are still obscenity laws on
the books of most states but it it is
legislation that is so narrow by
comparison to the Comstock act that it
it doesn't usually it doesn't usually
threaten mainstream kinds of in work
although now i'm saying that i have a
whole chapter about the 80s when in fact
a lot of lot of work that we considered
mainstream did come under attack and we
had a museum prosecuted in cincinnati
for a Mapplethorpe exhibit you know
we've had the police go into video
stores and graft copies of the tin drum
because they thought that it was child
pornography so I guess as I'm talking I
think you know there's some there is
there is a cyclical quality to all of
this but I believe that we have not been
starting over each time and I believe
that we had quite a bit of success in
opposing what was happening in the 80s
and we've had you know we've had our
share of success now but we have to keep
pushing we have to find one of the
things that we need to to work out right
now is to find a successor to the
freedom to read Protection Act to
continue the fight to restore reader
privacy and the other civil liberties
there are many civil liberties problems
in the
act my organization's most focused on
section 215 and and because of the book
angle but I you know I think we can take
a lot of pride in what you know what has
been achieved by organizations like the
ACLU and the ACLU itself has has not
always had shining moments you know the
ACLU in the 1950s was often compromised
with its highest principles but i can
tell you i wouldn't want to be in civil
libertarian in the 1950s either it would
it was a very dangerous difficult time
David you talk a little about the early
days of the FBI and going back to the
history I wonder if you could talk a
little about your opinion on whether or
not the heritage of the Palmer Raids
contributed to the genetic code of the
FBI well I think that you know the FBI
you know that the FBI there was one
constant in the FBI from the Palmer
Raids through the 50s and that was j
edgar hoover and we actually have an
author here Ken Ackerman is with us
tonight is written about at about Hoover
and the and the Palmer Raids something
he later tried to deny you had anything
to do with but the fact is that the way
the FBI conducted its business for the
next 40 or 50 years indicates that it
was all consistent with a very low
opinion of civil liberties and and you
know the only thing that stopped the FBI
from spying on us and breaking in was
legislation and you know we're having
some trouble right now making that stick
so talk about the magnitude of the
course of this
the people because you mentioned the
back in the turn of the 19th century the
Federalists and the anti-federalists and
having a tradition act there are also
other things throughout history during
the war where Lincoln put the
journalists in in jail for for their
opinions about the Civil War was guarded
you mentioned you Eugene Debs is there
the consequences as great now as it was
then whether or not you all sail people
being imprisoned for their opinions I
don't think you see as much of that for
sure I think there are a lot of
organizations today that are dedicated
to making sure that their members don't
get thrown into prison and it's an
important part of the free speech story
is that is the proliferation of trade
and professional groups groups
representing the press groups
representing publishers and booksellers
like me each of these groups that has
been burned by censorship has you know
has answered that with kind of an
organizational response and as a
consequence I spent a lot of my time you
know talking to booksellers who are
getting subpoenas for various things
that the police want and questions and
we're you know we are dealing with the
First Amendment issues of our members
all the time and so are the other groups
and and that's why there were a hundred
and fifty groups in the ACLU at the I
mean they weren't you know they weren't
all civil liberties groups there were a
lot of a lot of trade groups a lot of
professional groups auto civil rights
groups that were concerned about civil
rights in the aftermath of the roundup
of a Muslim immigrants
I talking about
and justice
more about how he changed with my life
yeah it was it was one of the most
dramatic moments really in the history
of free speech it was the justice was
Oliver Wendell Holmes who was at that
point in his 70s and Holmes was one of
it was probably the most respected
member of the supreme court at the time
one of the one of the biggest thinkers
and one of the most original minds but
he had written opinions all through the
war sending people to jail for for
passing out leaflets for making speeches
and he was the he was the man who wrote
the decision in the Deb's case sending
two EPs upholding Deb's is in prison and
only six months later he changes his
mind and largely as a result of lobbying
by a few very angry admirers of his he
changes his mind and and writes the
dissenting opinion in Abrams vs us that
gives us some of the most classic
language defending free speech that we
have today and that we depend on we
throw it in every letter that we write
you know it's it's our bedrock and he
did that against the his wife asked him
not to do it all the other Supreme Court
justices drove over to his house and
tried to talk him out of doing it but
from that point on from from the Abrams
case on he defended free speech and and
with Louis Brandeis in the minority but
ultimately his his point of view on the
free speech came to be what the Supreme
Court embraced and and you know the
doctrine that we live under today
it's a little more about how long pup
publishers and broadcasters and those
who often stand the shoes of speakers
individual speakers was it inevitable
that they became the four in the
forefront of the Civil Liberties
movement and is that is that it's tickle
coke or steady progress maybe you could
talk about the internal some of them
call me some of those publishers with
all due respect to my friends the
publishers and they are very good
friends some of those publishers were
dragged kicking and screaming into the
modern world the fact is there were you
know there was a cutting edge of
publishers who who went to battle
against censorship in and kind of drag
the rest of the association in with them
and the same was true of books hours and
librarians to in the beginning it's just
a few individuals I you know the in
Boston in the 20s the people who led
this filled the seats on on the
censorship committee were booksellers it
was called the Boston booksellers
committee and they they banned you know
2626 books over the course of a decade
and so we all changed our minds and and
librarians to I mean there was a time my
favorite story is about the the library
journal at one point did a survey of its
members of how they were dealing with
difficult books and and one librarian in
Atlanta talked about how she hiked out
she was hiding the books in the stacks
so that her patrons couldn't find them
so we've all come you know we've all
come a long way and and really the great
bravery that has been shown by
librarians over and over again over the
last six years particularly the for
Connecticut librarians who challenged
the National Security Letters
successfully even though under
tremendous burdens of under a gag order
and unable to even talk to their own
families about what they were going
through those are the people that I'm
talking about when I say that courage
and and belief you know in Liberty
remains very very strong
at least for many of us one thing in the
in the modern times that the Internet
has brought to us is a redefinition of
responsible journalism on the internet
anybody can basically publish anything
they want there's no peer review there's
no whatever anent and even if there are
people in condemn it you just put it off
in the Azores or something it doesn't
matter if is there a worry that that the
definition of truth is is going to be
harder to define in the future I mean
there are a lot of lies that came out in
the previous two elections and you know
you watch some of these like opportunity
intelligent first believe this and I
don't think they did but they were
willing to spout it and they couldn't be
nailed because they were on the internet
well to the extent that that's all all a
product of free speech are not going to
find me coming out against it I mean
even though I realized there are there
are legitimate questions about you know
what's happening to our level of
discourse but a newspaper reporter you
know he has to fair responsibility for
what he right and if he lies he's going
to get called to account on the internet
that's not true so that you know the
well I think you know I think we all
have to sharpen our our antenna and we
all have to be more skeptical of what we
read because we read you know they as
you say the opinion is proliferating I'm
more focused on what the government
would like to do to the internet if it
had a chance we've had we've seen two
efforts by Congress to censor the
internet directly and there are
innumerable issues before Congress right
now involving social networking and the
mandatory rating of websites that
constitute would constitute direct
government censorship if they were
passed so I got it I am much more
focused on that than the other dangerous
that was a perfect segue into the
question that I wanted to ask or bring
up the social networking sites the
regulation of material on the internet
is under a new guys and that is probably
the every other group in this country
has a voice has a franchise except for
young people and it seems as though on
civil liberties and friend first
amendment rights are expanding for
minorities for insurgents for prisoners
in Guantanamo and they are constricting
uh for for young people and um what you
know how do you see this playing out in
terms of government no I think it's a
very good point there are there are
still some pretty glaring exceptions in
terms of who enjoys free speech in this
country and kids are pretty low on the
ladder you know we we sponsor along with
the Association American publishers and
librarians banned books week because
there are hundreds of challenges last
year 500 challenges the books that were
approved for use in the schools but
which one parent or another believed for
because of their content should not be
there's a case in the Supreme Court this
year an involving students beach that
has a very good chance of going against
the free speech interest asserted there
and you know there is a there is a
concern as well that the kids are not
being educated about free speech to the
extent that they should be even though
I'm again being more optimistic by
Nature I'm more optimistic about I think
kids care very passionately about the
media and the censorship of media that
it concerns them and I think there are a
natural ally in the fight for free
speech if we can reach out to them but
it's it's not an easy thing to do
because teachers and principals were
scared to deal with these issues and
and it's hard to organize kids you know
behind their backs so but I but you're
absolutely right there's it's not that
it's not that we've reached free speech
nirvana here it's just that over the
course of nine years we've made a lot of
progress and we've got a long way to go
if there is one ken many of the
constraints on free speech today are
under the rationale of trying to avoid
people offending other groups and you
see this in form of universities speech
codes and another 22 cases come to mind
one is a case in a California University
I forget which where where somebody was
bound to up stepped on a flag arend a
paper drawing of the flag of a mas I
believe it was and that the picture had
had the name of Allah in it the person
who stepped on it didn't know that and
they are now being I believe expelled by
the university under under for offensive
speech the other is the don imus case
and I just wondered if you wanted to
talk about either of those well i think
i like to do with this one i have i have
a google search that for a free speech
that produces articles every day of the
free speech of free any article that
includes the words free speech I must
get 10 you know 12 articles a day about
free speech fights going on around the
country and and it says two things it
says one there is a lot of conflict a
lot of it's happening in in universities
and
the i miss you know the ayahs
controversy is a little atypical in that
sense but the other is that there are
people who are who are fighting these
efforts at censorship and that they take
the First Amendment very seriously today
we take it we assume that it's our
birthright and and whenever somebody
crosses us we're going to work quick to
run to the First Amendment to assert
that principle that's tremendous
progress in my mind so the evidence that
there's an increased conflict I think is
is a healthy sign but as I say I'm very
optimistic so I and sometimes overly
optimistic but I I think that that the
history of free speech gives us a lot to
hope for for the future for for
continuing to address the problems that
still exists thank you very much
Christopher finance new book from the
Palmer Raids to the Patriot Act a
history of the fight for free speech in
America he's president of the American
bookseller